we drove on saturday morning into the
town of warrenton
and we couldn't make the left that
google mouse was telling me i should
make at the rental car
because it was blocked
there was a police blockage and we had
to drive through
one side of the street was black lives
matter protest and the other side of the
street was an all lives matter protest
and
uh it was
fascinating to drive through and then i
realized after we had parked in this
sort of quaint little town in the middle
of what seemed to me like nowhere oh
we're gonna actually have to walk back
through this this protest and that
that'll be interesting
and
and i wrote about this also in this
evergreen piece that i wrote for natural
selections this week
we ended up on the side of the street
just because of where the restaurant was
with the all lives matter protesters
and talked to a couple of them
and while we were talking to a couple of
them one of the other all lives matter
post protesters started just
kind of throwing a fit and yelling and
he was standing in the street and he was
yelling at the black lives matter
protesters
and zach and i were saying to the two
people we're talking to who are very
calm
and you know we're making frankly in
many ways a lot of sense he said that's
not helping that's not helping anyone
here but it's certainly not helping you
send the message uh that you're actually
interested in everyone moving forward
into the future with some um you know
some some freedom and justice
uh but of course all movements have
their unhinged people and in this case
the unhinged person happens to be on the
side of all lives matter and that was
it's unfortunate whenever it shows up
anywhere but that that was the case
there uh we talked
uh to these uh to these people and they
were they seemed you know honorable and
um they were they were faithful they uh
in fact one of them was quoting
scripture at me which i didn't find
compelling as an argument for why all
lives should matter but you know any
more than i find um appeals to authority
when it's from the cdc compelling on
their own
but it was
fascinating
to also observe that if you just took
like nice mug shots like if you tried to
do like profile portraits of the people
the black lives matter protesters looked
more like
people that i see in the coffee shops
around here who i imagine i might have
more in common with who you know
probably think about eating locally and
eating organic and probably want to
spend a lot of time outside
and all of this and
and yet
the things that they were chanting were
the usual black lives matter chants that
i know to either be not what they claim
or to actually be inconsistent with
other things that they chant given
what's been on their website and you
know and much of which they've taken
down
uh but you know all of this is happening
in
a sort of a an exurb of dc you know
an hour out of dc like very far outside
uh
but in a context that i didn't i never
foresaw i never imagined that we would
run into black lives matter in all lives
matter protesters uh in warrenton
virginia and then we went back the whole
team went back and you know i and one of
the other parents the other parent who
was an actual chaperone and the team
like the person from the school who's
like the mentor sort of um
went back to like a what was it called
carousel zack this the the sweet shop
um which was its own cultural
extravaganza
and i thought ah this just reminds me of
nothing i've ever seen before this is
like this is the place where everyone in
the town comes for saturday night
and gets desserts that i don't recognize
even as food and none of the other sort
of portland kids were like i don't it's
it's a deep-fried twinkie is it okay i'm
not sure i want to eat that
um
so the whole thing was a little bit like
traveling to a different country in some
regards and then to have sort of people
from a different country but still with
the black lives matter and the all lives
matter people facing off against one
another and yelling at one another
okay so there was that
and then the next day we went um i'd
gotten us an airbnb for the night in dc
and we went first to arlington
which was super easy to be in you know
arlington had all the little cafes and
the good cappuccinos and all the stuff
that uh you know that that i think i
like and it was just easy to walk with
they had great bagels right zach
and then in dc
we had um
let's see i sent you three pictures
right zach yeah you want to show um
first scotus
so we walked by the supreme court
uh
and
it was on a this was a monday morning
so i guess it's the next this the next
morning it was a gray morning there
there was clearly a lot of signs of um
there having been
protests over the weekend but
while we were there there was just one
lone protester
who had a backpack on from which she was
blaring some sort of very angry music
and i can't read it from here but her
sign says something like
you know she's she's pro-choice
right um but then the other signs which
again i can't read i wonder if you could
put it on our little screen here zach
no you can't well maybe you can so i i
don't remember what's on the signs but
the one that's most yep
yeah so just just tell us what one of
them one of them says here
okay um
rights start at conception
and gay rights started conception and
then i think the one lying on the ground
says something like
um
atheists for life
and all three of those signs are
just not what we're expecting
and they speak to some protests that
i've yet seen yet to see any evidence of
elsewhere
and the idea you know trans rights begin
at conception
this
causes so many errors to be thrown right
away that it's really hard to even know
what to think and you know maybe the
point was
whoever whoever designed that sign and
was carrying it was trying to throw
errors in the in the minds of the of
pro-choice protesters um or they were
just themselves very confused or i don't
even know what but this you know this is
the supreme court of the united states
everyone that's a perfect perfect uh
indicator of the level of confusion of
the moment almost no matter what
explains it yeah yeah yeah
um so i guess actually the night before
then um the next picture zach is of the
rainbow over the white house
uh which we saw uh if you can show it
yeah um
we were
we had gone to the um national portrait
gallery
which was
uh fascinating there's a watergate
exhibit at the moment which is um quite
worth seeing
and we walked through the presidential
portraits and we're learning some things
i had been there back right when the
obama portraits had gotten there and
they're now on the move so they weren't
there
so it went uh so so there weren't so
barack obama wasn't there and there is i
imagine a sort of temporary one for
trump there but the uh
the bios they have one or two paragraph
bios for all of the presidents and the
farther back you go um the
the clearly less politicized excuse me
they are but they all seem pretty
straightforward they all seem to pretty
much describe the facts
until you get to trump and i wish i'd
taken a picture or you know i could tell
you exactly what it said but
uh you know as as we've said here before
um i'm not a fan of trump i didn't vote
for him
i didn't uh vote for the other guy in
the last election either but um i did i
i haven't voted for him
and
the description of him
on in the national portrait gallery was
so politicized and so not reflective of
actually a description of what it is
that he did as president and
any fair
analysis of the things that he
accomplished includes some things that
all americans should be able to get
behind no such things are mentioned and
what is mentioned is january 6th and i'm
not do you remember zach if the word
insurrection is used i don't remember
and i don't want it i don't want to
misquote
i don't remember exactly the word
yeah
so that that struck me as a tragic
disappointment in one of our most
important national museums to have it be
politicized in this way when this is
supposed to be about portraits of
presidents yeah in fact it's
um
decidedly unwelcoming of some large
fraction of the electorate which half
the electorate this has become this has
become the nature of
our system which is
at least on the one side
there is
a sort of sense that people who disagree
are
not entitled to the full rights of
citizens they're not entitled to have
their president um objectively
memorialize that you know it's it's
preposterous how could this how could
this possibly end well yeah no it's it's
not it's not okay it's not okay
um
so from there we we walked and we walked
to dinner and then we got sort of stuck
in a thunderstorm and we we uh got told
we needed to leave from in front of the
white house and it seemed like something
interesting might happen and so zach and
i hung out there for a while and nothing
interesting happened but we did see this
rainbow
[Music]
you